salut aujourd'hui je ne vous emmène pas
durant un mois avec moi à la place moi
si j'ai une autre idée je vous emmène
une journée avec mois non-stop
c'est une journée type de ce que je fais
depuis le mois de janvier le savoir
faire du spectacle en faisant des vidéos
et en faisant autre chose pour un
plateau avec vérino vous connaissez déjà
avec arthur ce que vous connaissez aussi
qui est passé sur ma chaîne
enfin bref tout commence quand je me
réveille
[Musique]
il est 10h30 je suis à l'hôtel et je me
réveille seulement maintenant parce que
je me suis couché tard hier soir
déjà parce que je me suis refait tout le
débat des présidentielles donc sa durée
3h30 je me suis regardée en replay avant
de me coucher bon s'éclate et puis
ensuite parce que j'étais en spectacle
hier soir je crois d'ailleurs que c'est
la date où il ya eu le plus de vous au
spectacle on s'est vraiment éclaté ce
ter qui complète vous donne les dates
d'avril je serai à mulhouse à sénas à
strasbourg à la vidéo city de paris le
samedi et j'avais dit qu'en afrique je
ferai une annonce pour les gens de
nantes
parce que les gens de nantes de vendée
et de bretagne ont été nombreux à dire
que je passais pas dans leur secteur
je vous ai proposé qu'on passe la
journée ensemble voici par quoi va
commencer ma journée
j'avais remarqué dans les blogs en ce
moment je suis malade une fois par mois
comme j'ai un rythme soutenu je prends
beaucoup de trains et tout çà et là le
matin première étape rejoindre le diable
est la dernière étape de la journée ce
sera de jouer au théâtre fémina c'est un
1200 places à bordeaux qui est
magnifique et on doit tous jouer comme
ça à 15 20 minutes et je sais pas encore
ce que je dois jouer ça va être un peu
le leitmotiv de cette journée mais je ne
sais pas encore ce que je vais faire sur
scène vient de recevoir un sms de diablo
d'heure leur diablo quand ils t'envoient
sms c'est ça c'est super drôle parce
qu'il parle vraiment comme un sms ça
doit le saouler d'écrire mais il le fait
à la voie mais il doit être persuadé que
peut-être ça va être retranscrit par
texte gens font assez toujours décrit
comment c'est bien une journée qui
parvient nous allons manger au
restaurant
va-t-elle de bordeaux pour rejoindre
l'équipe de cdiscount et simon puech
alias le jeu vidéo
il est seul
dans le tramway
il repense à sa vie d'avant mais il a dû
fuir
puisque
tu sais pas trop si c'est toi qui fais
des crises et les gens vibrent en tout
cas y ait une fuite vers l'au-delà vers
le dollar
même un petit peu après ben c'est le
diable oserais je voudrais pas dire mais
y'a de la relance sur la villette points
on a un sideman puis à chabihas jeu
idéal et il ya du site il ya du
cdiscount voir la ja awards et c'est ma
seconde qui se fout de moi parce que
j'ai de commander à l'apéro un allongé
mais vous avez vu ce matin c'était pas
évident pour moi de prendre un café
alors je prends un allongé à l'apéro tu
vois regarder il arrive et va longer
pour monsieur fait des petits travelling
des promis mme aubry
merci si tu connais pas le jeu idéal
foutu carbone j'en viens de regarder la
fin d'un film dans le dans le lit et je
croyais que j'allais m'endormir je
regardais la fin de waterworld j'ai la
flemme
c'est ça aussi parfois une journée j'ai
la flemme bon j'ai pas filmer la ce que
je venais de faire parce que juste avant
de regarder le film je répondais à l'e
mail sur l'ordi je regarde un peu les
commentaires aussi la vidéo d'hier le
numéro du prénom en fait je voulais
peut-être faire mon numéro avec qui ce
qu'ils sont venus voir le spectacle le
connaissent mais j'ai peur que sur une
soirée où j'ai peu de temps sur scène
en tout cas où je vous parle en
spectacle en entier soit un peu trop
brutale de dire aux gens et salue et
vous dis d'apprendre qu'ils portaient
peut-être que ça se passerait bien mais
je sais pas si j'aurai les cojones de
d'attaqué comme ça un plateau avec ça
c'est un numéro que j'ai jamais isolé
encore
donc je voulais le voir je crois que je
déciderai sur place je suis ce sera
peut-être intéressant comme d'habitude
on fait un mois complet de faire une
journée mais une journée au chu mais
encore une fois c'est plein d'énergie
alors maintenant que j'ai compris tu vas
pouvoir
je te fais des sms mais des pages
entières à l'usé pas vu parce que parce
que je lui ai dit forcément pour les sms
alors là il me fait des pages dms tient
réponse et joaquin alors restaurant de
la fal crevettes j'écoute
pourquoi parti de l'in glorieuse frank
michael en concert avec ses musiciens
pourquoi tu as changé de vie non ça
toujours été celle ci a semé ça c'est
pour le rodage sans mais oui si après on
mettra toutes les lettres mais là c'est
une manière de dire que pour l'instant
je suis juste un mot nage maintenant
c'est jacking sa dérive c'est joachim et
sa guitare
qui toi tu passes par des portes
dérobées patrick et oui il ya dérobé
d'affaires du groupe ya plus de portes
du to play bonjour c'est très bien mika
patrick sans faille pour l'une des
russes communiqué
[Musique]
alors là on fait un bond dans le temps
des secondes et le 1er avril
j'étais en train de monter
tranquillement la vidéo qui sera
aujourd'hui et il me manque des roches
je ne sais pas où ils sont comme vous
voyez je suis toujours en tournée donc
je peux pas retourner une vidéo ce matin
l'écrire la tournelle à monter donc je
mette celle ci quand même
il me reste encore un petit peu de suite
mais il me manque plein de choses entre
17h et 23h
j'avais fait un interview avec une
chaîne youtube j'avais fait un interview
aussi également pour france 3 il ya tous
les passages dans les loges où on
faisait les cons avec tout le monde
bref je pense que je ne sais pas du tout
j'ai encore deux trois roches qui me
reste dans mon téléphone donc là je vais
vous les montées je vais vous des
maîtres après mais c'est pour vous
expliquer qu'il va y avoir ce bug
temporel et croyez moi bien je suis le
premier dégoûté
vous pensez à coeur c'est sûr mais il
est des artistes de larry king jouet du
partage dans le conte a mis sur la fiche
on n'est pas conviée
on annonce airbus nouvelle est liée en
premier league car pour exporter abbring
entraîne évidemment st pauli secours
vous êtes vraiment fait
la salle est un jeune artiste talentueux
qui dure
ils joueront dans ce cas si maintenant
on va manger les manifestants vous
pouvez dire des trucs drôles c'est pour
une vidéo mauvaise personne
mais c'est bien lui en dise parce que
matt hall te dit ça ça devient je vois
la coupe c'est pour une copie je ferai
comme fille est partie aux toilettes
est-ce que je peux essayer d'avoir
quelqu'un qui discute avec patrick chan
traître et du coup la tondeuse à gazon
oui c'est quoi
alors c'est simple on a vendu dp3 suis
parti il va côtoyer des partis en bateau
lui qui démarre en bateau des loyers que
tu m'a dit qu'il avait bien les voyages
en australie qui au final les pâtures
oméga web favoris là il se donne rien
pour avoir du cash
alors ça ça tarde à 6,5 obliger les
regarde ça c'est une très très bonne
illustration
on s'est couché tard très tard j'ai pas
filmer les dernières minutes à l'hôtel
et je pense qu'on s'en passe très bien
le prochain bloc sera le 1er mai vous
avez bien compris c'est le 1er de chaque
mois j'ai serré encore de trouver un
angle différent mais vous pouvez aussi
m'en proposait un dans les commentaires
me dire qu'est ce que vous aimeriez sur
le blog sachant que j'ai un mois pour le
faire c'était assez marrant de vous
montrer tout ça de l'intérieur si ça
vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
et comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne vous pourrez
regarder la dernière vidéo que j'avais
fait
et puis moi je vous donne rendez vous
très bientôt ce sera mardi ou mercredi
ciao